hello
this is undertaker i'm a lymph
implementation expert with
cloudlings.com
and today i'll be talking about
regulatory compliance and best practices
and how a limb can actually help you in
laboratories
ahead of the curve starting with we'll
be discussing about
the regulatory compliance of why and who
of it will be discussing about
major compliance and best practices
across different industries
we'll then talk about the benefits of
using a lymph and then just a summary of
the key takeaways from the discussion
starting with let's talk about what is
the regulatory compliance all about
well a regulatory compliance is a set of
laws regulations guidelines
that an organization needs to adhere to
they act as the moral compass to ensure
a laboratory is legally
and ethically sound they are governed
both nationally
and internationally and may vary from
one industry to another or one
laboratory to another
based on industry's end goals so who
takes care of these regulatory
compliance who addresses them who
sets them those would be your regulatory
agencies
so regulatory agencies are independent
government body
responsible for setting and enforcing
the regulatory compliance
required to govern regulatory
laboratories and ensure that they are
the auto industry and international
standards
some of these regulatory agencies
include the fda
the iso the gdpr
and hipaa we'll be discussing each of
them a little more in detail
shortly so before we talk about
all the compliance and what are the
requirements let's
understand why are they important so why
are regulatory complaints important
primarily because they're legally
mandatory
anything any laboratory that is legally
authorized
automatically builds trust within the
community
because they follow a set of guidelines
they have to assure quality
and public safety and also ensure
standardization
and data protection data protection like
we're going to learn now is one of the
most important aspects of any regulatory
compliance
now we have a laboratory that is legal
legally authorized
it builds trust within the community it
assures quality
and public safety and ensure
standardization
and data protection it obviously
increases the marketability of its
business
hence the next or the most important
part of why it is
important is because regulatory
compliance helps your lab increase
marketability of the business
but with everything that is important
also come certain challenges
some of the most important or two of the
most primary challenges that any
laboratory faces
while trying to meet regulatory
compliance includes
it been expensive and time consuming why
though
well to meet your regulatory compliance
you need to have a specific set of
infrastructure
and specific personnel who would be
dedicated to ensuring that you meet
all compliance requirement to set up the
infrastructure and hire the
employee is actually both time consuming
and money consuming
hence for any laboratory to meet
regulatory compliance they need
to make sure they need to ensure these
two points that is expense and the time
also we live in a environment we live in
a world that is constantly developing we
live in a
world that is com constantly driven by
innovations and new technologies at
every
a new point so every compliance needs to
change
periodically to meet these evolving
industry requirements
as such laboratories also need to be
alert
and adaptive to the new changes and
actively implement them in their
laboratory workflows
this comes up as a new challenge the
third or most important challenge for
any laboratory when trying to meet
regulatory compliance
now that we have discussed about the
challenges and why it is important
let's talk a little bit about some of
the best practices
that a lab can implement that you can
implement to ensure that you can easily
meet these complex requirements
starting with always have a clear
determination of the end goals of the
laboratories
you should be clear about what is end
goal of a laboratory
whether you are a testing lab whether
you are a research lab whether you are a
manufacturing unit
you should be extremely clear about your
labs and goals
you should have you should proactively
establish policies and procedures
that ensure that you meet compliance and
quality requirements
should also have a well-documented and
communicated code of conduct
so that your employees know what
behavior is expected out of them
also you should have a separate
compliance team that would be
responsible
for meeting the complex requirements and
also proactively collaborate with the
rest of the team
for effective cross-departmental
communication
your employees should be held
accountable based on their information
and positions employ accountability is
important and you should also have a
documentation of any corrective or
preventive actions that you take
in terms of such important
accountability
you should also have constant monitoring
of all activities performed in the lab
so you should regularly conduct internal
audits with for continuous monitoring of
active arrays
also because you're holding employees
accountable
and you expect a certain set of or like
responses or behavior from them
you should ensure that they are also
compliant strength so that you so
influence lines training of
which is extremely important your
employees should become completely and
properly trained so that they know what
is to be expected from them
and then adopting a risk-based approach
for analysis and management of risks
so that if you come up with issue or you
face an issue
you have a you have a proper risk this
analysis and approach available for it
for you to quickly handle and manage
that issue so
these are some of the examples of the
best practices that you could implement
in a laboratory
to ensure that you are you are
regulatory and you have a methodology
complex
so next we're going to talk about some
of the regular of
major regulatory compliance sequence
across traffic industry
starting with let's we'll talk about the
21ca for part 11 compliance from fda
we would then move on to the iso 17025
compliance that is extremely important
for any analytical testing lab
we would then talk about some of the
important good laboratory practices that
would act as guidelines
for best lab practices or best practices
in the lab
we would then move to some clinical
laboratory or compliance requirements
regard
including gdpr hipaa and clayer
we would then discuss some biobanking
information uh information including the
iso 15189 iso two zero three eight seven
and some best practices that is bo
suggests to help your lab meet those
regulatory requirements
and then we'll end the discussion
talking about the food safety
modernization act and hssp that is the
hazard analysis critical
control point for full laboratories
starting with let's talk about the 21
cfr part levels from science
the three major requirements of the 21
cfr part 11 compliance
includes confidentiality of electronic
records
digital signatures on electronic records
and maintaining an audit rail
a lims allows you to easily maintain or
manage all records in
electronic format for every record that
is present in the limbs
every user who accesses that record
could be provided with a role-based user
access permission
which means only users who have the
access information
access permission under your laboratory
hierarchy will be able to access that
electronic record
for the rest of them it will be hidden
or blocked off
even for users who have access
permission they will require to
authenticate their permission by
digitally signing in into the system
and providing a valid set of
reasons before they could access
electronic records
and all of these activities will be
recorded in an audit trail
that will be available at any point of
time for internal audits and checking
what has happened at what point of time
and who performed the activity
moving on we'll talk about the
most commonplanet analytical testing lab
that is iq17025 requirements
it could be broadly classified into
three different requirements management
resource and personal starting with
let's talk about
the management requirements the
management requirements
pertain to the operation and
effectiveness of the quality management
system within a lab
this includes the control of records
internal audits doc organism structure
document control and purchasing services
and supplies
like we just discussed a limp allows you
to easily control all the records that
you have in the lab
via electronic media you can organize or
you can organize the users based on
organizational structure
and only limit or access information of
access permissions can be limited based
on your user's position in the labs that
are
your business hierarchy and then every
activity can be internally recorded by
the internal audits
and they can be referred to at any point
of time requirement
next we come to document control so why
is document control important
we are living in the governed era
everything is changing the protocols the
testing are changing protocols the
handling samples are changing protocols
for
workflows are changing what is the
guidelines have expected behavior is
changing
so in this changing goal where you have
new guidelines you have
updated sops you have new workflows and
methodologies
it's very important that your laboratory
users have access to all of these
documents
it is also important that every document
accessible to these users
be properly reviewed before being
published or made accessible to the
users
this is where a lens comes in limbs
allows you to manage all the documents
at one place
update versions of the documents as and
when required
and also uh for you provide access to
the user for these documentations
further requirements limbs can also help
you keep a track of the vendors and
services
required for purchasing and supplies
next we're going to talk about
the resource requirements that includes
the addresses the competence of staff
and instruments
like we discussed for the challenges one
of the major challenges is to have a set
of personnel who are compliance trained
also during the best practices we
discussed that is very important
to train your employees to understand
for them to understand what is expected
of them
also it is very important that every
employee or every and every instrument
technology that your lab uses is
assigned to employee
who is skilled enough to handle her
assigned to a personnel who is clearly
love to handle that
a lens allows you to keep the track of
all of your staff members in the lab
keep a record of the training history
and also make sure that you mark the
level of competency that each of these
staff members have
in terms of their training history
also it allows you to keep a track of
all instruments that you have in the lab
along with the individual components it
is very important that
instruments are properly calibrated and
maintained when you're running a test on
them
otherwise your results are going to be
error prone so
a lens allows you to keep a track of all
the laboratory instruments that you have
in the lab
along with the calibration maintenance
cycles and also allot you whenever the
next calibration of maintenance cycle is
needed
next we will talk about the process
requirements including
addressing sample and testing
methodology the quality and reporting of
tests and calibration results
this includes test and calibration
methods and method validation
ensuring the quality of test calibration
results
measure dressability reporting of
results
and review and of requests and tenders
and contacts
so for any testing laboratories one of
the most important aspects is them
receiving the test order
it is very important for them to be able
to review all the test orders that they
receive and only accept those
that tick all the boxes or meet all the
requirements that a laboratory has
a limp allows you to quickly access
access all the requests that have been
sent them review them and only accept
those that make sense so that meets all
the requirements once the result test is
accepted
you can then you integrate limbs with
any analytical instrument to
automatically transfer the test results
from the instrument into limbs
with minimal inhuman interaction to
diminish any human prone errors
and then once the results are in the
system you can send them for validation
you can set a
set of validation workflow validation
rules you can select
multiple test results that you want to
send for validation and then you can
select
for each of these stressful so you can
select specific individuals verifiers or
validating
officers should be responsible for
validating the stress results
all of this is ultimately going to
assure the quality of your final test
results
and when they're ready flims allows you
to generate custom coa or custom reports
so that you can which meets all of your
regulatory requirements
that can be released back to the
customer it also allows you to keep a
track of the quality of the samples via
quality control
and detection of trends virtual analysis
reports
where you can easily detect trends
across different samples
and quickly pick out outliers for
further action
so here is a quick example of how an
audit trail would look like for a limp
where you would have information like
regarding the activity time and date
actual information about what activity
was performed and the name of the user
who is performing the activity
this can be referenced through at any
point of time to keep a track of
whatever is happening in the
laboratory so it's like a continuous
monitoring of all the information
all the processing activities taking
place in the lab and you can use it both
for the internal and external audits as
well
moving on when it's going to talk about
glp that is the good lab practices and
the many main facets of it
include quality measurability
dress to talk a little bit more in
details
some of the good lab practices that you
can follow include
following fops that are standard
operating procedures
which can be easily made available via a
document management model
document management option proper
labeling of reagents
this is extremely important imagine a
scenario where you have to use a
particular reagent but you do miss
labeling of each and you end up using
something completely different
and your entire test goes gets messed up
so it's very important that all of your
reagents are properly
labeled a limp allows you to keep your
track of
all of the individual reagents that you
have in the lab you can also generate
specific barcodes
that can be printed into labels that you
can use to properly label
and then follow the reagents journey in
the laboratory
to make sure that proper reagents are
used at proper stages
another important aspect is assigning
instruments to skilled analysts
like you were just uh talking about a
lymph allows you to easily keep the
track
of the personal that you have the
competency levels and then according to
that
you can assign instruments through these
skilled analysts
calibrating and maintaining instruments
and then reporting of this data in a
in a in a coa custom ua that would meet
the regulatory requirements
and also help you to archive a secure
account of the results
moving on we'll be talking about some of
the important clinical requirements
starting with the eu gdpr that would be
very important for any
any subject under the european union so
the three main aspects of the eu gdpr
includes
maintaining reports of all processing
activities which you can easily manage
via
audit trail in a lymph protecting
sensitive information of eu subjects
and authenticating the laboratory
activities
so a limbs allows you to de-identify or
desensitize data
that you enter so in case you have a
patient information they need to
de-identify defer anonymize
a limp allows you to do that and
restrict information access
from any user until unless they
authenticate that they
have authority to access their data and
also they'll have to authenticate a
reason as to why they need to access the
data
next we have the hipaa compliance that
again talks about
role-based access permission to staff
for safeguarding phi
so like we just discussed bhi or
protected health information is a very
important aspect
of any clinical laboratory so in order
to make sure that this data is hidden
and the patient identified
identification is properly hidden and
maintained
it is very important for any laboratory
to ensure that phi data is safeguarded
ellipse allows you to have a user
rule-based access permission
so that only users who have the
authority to access the data will be
able to access that
and that way they can save or safeguard
the psi from any staff member
lymph also comes an audit trail and
generally any limb should come with a
proper data encryption system and data
security system to ensure
that the data is properly secured and
only accessed by author
authorized access permitted users only
next we have declare requirements that
talks again about document management
and how important it is to make sure
that all protocols are in place
with the kovic scenario in our site i
think this is very important especially
for laboratories and
clinics that are actually handling such
or such important research
sensitive for samples laboratory
inventory management and tracking
so like we were discussing any lab that
has particular reagent systems can be
easily tracked and all reagents and loss
can be maintained using the inventory
module or inventory management tracking
from a limbs
quality control and quality assurance so
in lims
allows you to easily keep the track of
any quality control data that you have
and for any of these quality data you
can easily detect trends across samples
and then also specify outliers and take
a responsible action
based on that and then the instrument
calibration mentioned
that as we've seen is a very important
part of any complex requirements and
something that can easily be achieved
using a limbs
because we will next we will be talking
about some of the buyer banking
requirements
starting with the use of 15189
compliance requirements
again this talks about protecting
confidential information that is the phi
protected health information
defining users of user role-based
authorities
and responsibilities protecting data and
information from other unauthorized
access
documenting operational details and
ensuring accessibility
to authorized users only and validating
the system
and the test results and the process to
retrieve the
information so all of these requirements
we have just discussed where a lymph
allows you to de-identify sensitive
patient information that can only be
accessed via a rule-based access
formation based on
a use of authority in the laboratory all
data or all test results uploaded can go
through a
properly set up validation workflow so
that everything is validated
and data can be protected from
unauthorized use access
based on user's position in the labs
hierarchy
next we'll be talking about the ice iso
20387 compliance requirements
again for biobanks and again it talks
about this importance of securing phi
having an audit trail so that you can
record the activities including the
dates and time
of all biobanking activities that
they're doing in the lab and maintaining
the calibration of equipment
as well as assigning tough competent
technicians would be responsible for
executing them
next we have some best practices that
isbo suggests for biobanks to make sure
that they meet these complex
requirements
that includes managing and tracking
samples and locating stored samples
an order trail and user-based access
role permissions
a list allows you to track the samples
from accession till disposal
throughout its its lifecycle in the
laboratory
right from the moment you accept a
sample in the lab till the moment it is
disposed
shipped off or destroyed or limps can
actually help you track the entire life
cycle
also in case you're storing a particular
sample in the laboratory
because it talks about biobanks the
storage is a very important aspect
a list allows you to easily keep a track
of where a sample is stored in the real
life
and when you need to actually pull up
the sample information all you need to
do is go to the limbs
under the details it will tell you where
the sample is stored let can easily look
at that in real time
because we were talking about phi let me
show you how
a limbs can help to protect pha as you
can see this is a set of information
about
patients that have been registered under
a lab under the coveted language family
as you can see the names are hidden out
of the identifier
as such no user will be able to view
their information about the patient's
name and any other details
until unless they have access formation
authority to access it
and even then they'll have to
authenticate their access by
digitally logging in or digitally
finding into the system and putting a
valid reason as to why they're accessing
it
next we're going to talk about some of
the
food safety management or food safety uh
requirements
that the food labs require before we
talk about
the different acts or different
compliance requirements of
the food safety laboratory food testing
lab let's understand
why is it important let me give an
example
of an of a case that happened around in
2008 in 2009
where approximately 700 people were
infected with salmonella infection
this traced back to the peter
corporation of america
uh so this is uh this was raised back by
the peanut corporation of america to the
king nut brand of peanut butter
as such the person investigators traced
the outbreak to a georgia factory
it resulted in the criminal charges
against the ceo of the factory and two
more employees
and those charges actually included
fraud obstruction of justice and
selling of adulterated food another
incident happened with
jba circo corporation it's the jvh mr
food call
but they have to recall approximately 4
860 pounds
of imported boneless beef products why
because the us department of
agriculture's food safety
and inspection services during one of
the regular
routine inspections found crisis or
found confirmed positive presence of e
coli
in these three samples in one of the
cases as you can see
one had the recall that the affected
business
and the other ended up in interrupting
criminal charges against cu
so in both cases it is established that
is very important
that laboratories follow a specific set
of food safety regulations and rules
to ensure that their food labs have
proper standards that can meet the
safety regulations and also
uh bring off food uh produce food active
products that actually meet the
revelation requirements and the safety
requirements
which is why it's incredibly important
for any food testing or manufacturing
unit
to meet the regulatory requirements of
the food safety act
two of the major food safety aspects we
discussed today would include
mrs may and hsscp talking about the ssma
or the food safety modernization act
it was instituted in january 2011 by the
fda
to allow them to check what protocols
the word for
method regulations is a food testing
laboratory practicing
of food manufacturing unit practicing to
ensure that the products are safe for
consumption
some of the uh important points to
remember under the fsm
includes traceability of food samples
through the supply chain
to ensure data quality and assure safety
addressing an easy tracking of food
contamination issues
implementing corrective and preventive
measures to eliminate the risk of
contamination
so food labs it is very important to
have a complete visibility of samples
from farm to sport
a lens allows a lab to exactly do that
also a leaf allows the sample to be
accessible with a barcode like maybe a
one-dimensional or a two-dimensional
barcode
or maybe rfid that states that the
sample right some form fill the fork
that is right from accession into the
disposal packaging
or further marketing and it also allows
easily trace a final product or a
package product
back to the raw materials easy tracking
also includes
maintaining the chain of custody that
easily tells us of laboratory at what
point of time
which technician was responsible for
handling that food item while handling
that sample
and when we have passed over the desk
definition this entity helps to track
the contamination
issues and also implement proper
collective and preventive measures based
on that information
next let's talk about the hfccp
that includes capturing of sample and
test information
to prevent a formulated preventive
control plan
document and review all procedures and
predefined sops
this assessment through identification
of physical chemical and biological
hazards
self-training staff training and
competency assessment
and periodic tracking of information
related to these incidents
so in summary a limb should actually
help allow the hssap requirements
by being able to completely trace the
sample information from extending to
disposal
track all information related to a test
including when it was ordered
when it was processed who processed it
who validated it when it was validated
and any other information regarding the
reporting
it will help you keep a track of all of
your like lab documents
at one place for easy review and
accession and then you can
also maintain those soft training
requirements and make sure that only
people who are competent enough i have
made or uncertain responsibility to
handle a particular sample
and of course periodic tapping of
everything via the audit tray
so let's see how our limbs actually have
certainly in the chain of custody
as you can see here there's a small of
glimpse of how
limbs are actually helps maintain
chainsaw custody so
as a sample passes through the lab right
from inception or excession
to packaging or test change packaging
and final release
it goes through multiple hands a limb
allows you to keep the track of all of
these separate
individual people who are handling the
example at one point
also helps you keep track of when it was
transferred and why it was transferred
from one technician to another
as such it's very easy to mention or
change the structure into tracker
samples
and also implement kappa or collective
and preventative actions
based on leaf genocide details
so that was all about the different
regulatory compliance that
we have across different industries and
some of the key takeaways that we did
or had from today's discussion includes
an overview
of what the different regulatory
compliance and best practices are
available for different laboratories
across different industries
and how a lens can actually help all
these laboratories
comply with the regulatory requirements
and follow the best practices to stay
here of the curve
so as you can see the maintenance gist
of all of these compliments
is proper tracking of samples managing
of documents
ensuring that you have a proper task
that you can handle that is trending
enough to handle
and all the instruments are properly
recorded results are validated
and everything is listed and recorded at
one place that can be easily and quickly
referred to
when audited so that was all about this
discussion thank you
for being your passion and listening to
me this was really nice thank you
and have a nice day